It was easy.
Capturing my father,
pretending to be a security guard,
if only the sight of Grass Ray was enough, the machines would have been there at any time. What you're
after is the president's miscellaneous items. There's something I want to
accomplish. I'm going to cover the
enormous cost of the space development project.  War sharing is supported behind the scenes. That's what
I
want to do, Dad. The
shallow interest structure of war sharing is
inviolable. If it is easily destroyed, the earth will be exhausted by proxy wars.
Companies will compete for a limited slice of the pie, and
profits will dwindle.  It's all you can do.
There's a better way. Just
sell all the assets of the Disadvantage Group to Earth. You can create an economy of deterrence by taking advantage of the tense relationship between
Earth and corporations, where you don't know when a war will break out on Earth. That's right.
If you do that, there will be no need to start a war on Earth.
You were half a Persiant.
Conflict Area
Don't you just want to avenge your grudge against Spacia by suddenly giving them arms? I
can't fill your stomach with grudges,
though.
Spacyan.  If only those with rights and interests are
exploiting things as they are now, and
nothing will change without power, then I will
take away that power.